Eric Schlosser author of reefer madness
all it says about you under your picture
on the dust dust jacket is Eric
Schlosser is a correspondent for The
Atlantic Monthly and the author of Fast
Food Nation he is currently at work on a
book about the American prison system
was that your idea to have so little
biographical information
it wasn't solely my idea but I've really
tried as a writer to put the subject
matter before me and and there are a lot
of writers who I really admire whose
whose life story is part of the process
I love Hunter Thompson's work for
example but for me I'm really trying to
take the stories I write about the
subjects I write about and make them you
know first and foremost but I don't have
anything I feel I need to hide or any no
convictions yet or nothing no no
terrible scandals the jihad you made a
splash with this book Fast Food Nation
when did it come out and what's it about
it came out two years ago and it's an
investigative work about the fast food
industry in America and its impact on
agriculture our economy or labor force
and how we eat and what we look like
have you changed your eating habits
since you did it not that much I still
pretty much eat what I did before I just
don't eat them eat these foods in the
same places I don't go to the big fast
food chains anymore why I just don't
want to give them my money having
learned how they operate haven't learned
about their business practices I choose
not to spend my money there but I still
like french fries I just buy them from
different venues what's the number-one
thing you don't like about these big
businesses that run these fast-food
places I think once they got big to a
certain point there they really lost
touch with a kind of a core humanity
they treat workers as though they're
completely interchangeable parts of
their operating machinery they really
have not taken responsibility for the
impact that they have on our
agricultural system and what's happening
in their supplier slaughterhouses etc so
you know there's a chain that I eat at
in California called in and out and it's
a fast food chain
serves pretty much the same foods but
they pay decent wages it's real food and
I think in the fast food industry
they've reached a certain size and and
lost touch with some basic human values
are they a success they've been a huge
success but I think that their success
is beginning to wane I think the
American fast-food industry reached its
peak around the year 2000 and is now
starting to decline and McDonald's lost
money for the first time in its history
last year and I think people are going
to still want fast food but the era of
these gigantic centralized restaurant
chains serving food that tastes
everywhere exactly the same I think may
be ending and and smaller companies are
going to prosper so I don't I don't
think that McDonald's is going to
disappear but I don't know that it's
gonna grow it anywhere near the rate it
has in the past and it may even shrink
in your book that we're talking about
today reefer madness you break it up in
three sections pornography and marijuana
but the middle one is the Strawberry
Fields yeah did you happen to get onto
that through your book on Fast Food
Nation it actually happened the other
way around
I started out writing about migrant
workers for the Atlantic Monthly and
spent almost a year of looking at
migrant workers and following the
harvest and it was after the editors at
Rolling Stone read that piece in which
had taken all these complex economic and
historical forces and told them through
the story of your strawberry and where
it comes from the editors at Rolling
Stone asked me to do the same thing for
fast food to look behind the counter and
take this commodity that we all take for
granted and show where it comes from and
the systems behind it before you went to
the fields the the California farm
fields and the migrant workers where
were you
where'd you live I live in New York City
how long have you lived there I was born
there and I lived there my first 18
years then went to university in
graduate school and living in Vermont
briefly and now live in New York City
again
where'd you go school I went to
Princeton undergraduate and got a
graduate degree in history from Oxford
in why Vermont Vermont will seem like a
nice quiet place to try and be a
playwright and a novelist but it wasn't
a very successful experiment I started
out as a fiction writer and was
unsuccessful in that and moved to New
York City worked for a film company for
a while and was not very happy with that
got an opportunity to write a brief
piece for The Atlantic Monthly they ran
it and then gave me a bigger assignment
and that's pretty much what I've been
doing ever since other than the obvious
that your books didn't sell why didn't
you make it as an almost I don't know
you know I may be like the comedian who
who still wants to do Hamlet but I but
part of me thinks I'm better at fiction
and and and and that's sort of writing
that I am at this but I can't say why
maybe I was a lousy novelist or maybe
maybe it's just the timing wasn't right
it's hard to say I tried this book a
reefer madness I hoped and tried to get
published before Fast Food Nation but
publishers weren't interested in it so
it's it's hard to say how much is the
quality of the material and and how much
is the marketplace and what the
marketplace wants why did they get
interested after Fast Food Nation I
you have to ask them I mean I think that
these subjects are relevant I try to
write about things I care about and I
think are important but you know times
change in the in the paperback edition
of Fast Food Nation at the end in trying
to explain the success of that book I'd
like to think it's the brilliance of my
prose but realistically I think that if
if Fast Food Nation had been published 5
or 6 years earlier I I don't know if it
would have found a readership it's very
hard to say you know why something
succeeds or fails in the moment I think
people wrote beautiful books that were
published on September 12th or in
September of 2001 and no one will ever
hear of those books I have friends
who've written wonderful books that
don't get reviewed so I
I can't really explain the success I
just try to write about what I care
about and see what happens
Princeton and Oxford yeah well what was
the family life before you got there
like and what were your parents like
they still around my parents are still
alive my parents are wonderful
I admire my father more than any man
I've ever met and I had a very happy
childhood I was you know compliance he's
in retirement but he was a television
executive full name Herbert schlosser
that's a Herbert Schlosser of NBC so
Herbert sponsor of NBC yeah and you know
at this point I say no kidding I mean I
grew up with that name rather prominent
huh in the business tell our audience
what he did he was a television
executive for many years he rose up the
ranks and he was head of NBC at one
point and then you know I feel like the
film Network could have been based in
some ways on on what happened to my
father my father represented a very
old-fashioned notion of public service
and in television and you know he was
involved in all kinds of interesting
shows like laugh-in and comedies but he
also had a very strong belief and in
public service and documentaries and and
his departure from NBC I think was was a
turning point not because he was leaving
but but that period was a turning point
in which ratings became paramount in
which radies ratings were suddenly being
published in the newspaper and the way
that nobody outside the industry ever
thought about them and I think that you
know those notions of fairness like the
Fairness Doctrine and the idea of having
a documentary in primetime about
anything except Michael Jackson is
inconceivable today but it was a very
tough business
very cutthroat business but in watching
my father and growing up I felt like he
was a real man of honor and integrity
and was able to succeed without being a
slime ball like a lot of people are in
that business quickfacts
when was he head of NBC he was head of
NBC in the early 1970s and I think he he
left around 1970
eat something like that and how old a
man is he today he is 77 what's he doing
he's in semi-retirement he's an advisor
on various telecommunications issues he
worked for RCA after that and was you
know continuing to get involved in new
businesses and was helped set up the A &
E channel one of the first big cable
channels and has been with involved in
the internet businesses and he's a very
vital active person but what was
interesting for me is you know people
have accused Fast Food Nation of being
anti corporate anatta business and I'm
really not that way at all I mean I grew
up in that kind of household and it's
just the kind of corporate sensibility
of the of the 50s 60s and 70s very very
different from that of the 80s and 90s
and so you know I grew up where profits
were important but in a household where
profits were considered an important but
they didn't you know they weren't the
the only criteria and there were other
values that mattered as well how about
your mom my mother has been involved in
in the dance world she worked for many
years of the Martha Graham Dance Company
in New York City and you know III had an
incredibly fortunate upbringing in a
sense that my father's work was
interesting it it encompassed both news
and and the entertainment worlds and and
my mother has a very literary vent and
and and wherever as my father would be
reading history my mother would be
reading novels and fiction and her
father was a was a painter so I had a I
had a very I had a very stimulating
upbringing very very fortunate well
define kind of a broadly your I know if
you call it political views but your
attitude because you got some pretty
sensitive subjects here the marijuana
sales and the prison sentences and all
that stuff and the migrant workers and
also the porno industry to find it all
what do you think define I think what I
think about the black what the world
under now
just about the world in general how do
you approach the you know what would you
call yourself you remember a political
party a politically politically
independent I mean it sounds corny but
but a lot of my work and having studied
American history extensively is trying
to make America live up to its own
ideals and and to try to reconcile what
we say we are and who we say we are with
how we actually live and and and how the
government behaves so again you know
I've been accused of being anti
corporate anti-business a socialist a
communist and yet in my own mind there
have been periods in our history where
my own view of the world isn't that
unusual isn't that odd you know in terms
of Fast Food Nation the kinds of
recommendations that I called for at the
end of the book would have been in
keeping with what Eisenhower would have
had in place if you look at the
Eisenhower era we had strict antitrust
enforcement high proportion of labor
union membership you know graduated
income tax so you know in defending
myself against critics and and
particularly now with this
administration I would say that you know
the people who are running the Congress
and the White House are radicals and and
I don't feel as though I am on some
issues I'm very liberal politically I
spent a year looking at murder for the
Atlantic Monthly and wrote about the
victims rights movement and you know the
National Rifle Association distributed
that piece and you know really liked the
piece so hopefully if you had a complex
view of the world it's not easy to easy
to categorize you but but certainly what
I've tried to do with my investigative
work is tell stories that the mainstream
media is ignoring for one reason or
another and particularly to bring the
voices of people who may ignore to the
public whether it's migrant workers
whether it's you know the meatpacking
workers I wrote about in Fast Food
Nation and so I guess it would take
someone else to to category to
categorize me neatly
ideally two different people with two
different political points of view could
read one of my books get something from
it come away feeling differently I mean
I try I try at the end of each section
or try at the end of the book to propose
solutions to her to make recommendations
but the bulk of the work is
investigative reporting and and
hopefully is balanced and tries to be
fair you interviewed a woman by the name
of Dyna Hartley you know Hartley nina
hartley you know ni na yeah we had
somebody at work too at our place called
9s it goes back and forth
who was she and why janitor
well when I interviewed her if you had
you know passed by us in the restaurant
you would have thought that she was a an
attractive aerobics instructor or maybe
you know a sociology graduate student
but she's actually one of the most
legendary and and successful porn
actresses in America and very smart very
articulate and she described for me the
labor practices of the of the industry
the the three essays in this book reefer
madness you know are about black markets
and in a way it's a business book so in
in the in the pornography section nina
hartley was a very very good guide to
some of the labor practices in the
industry and so why would you
interviewer what would you learn from
her I learned you know what the wage
rates are I learned what the life is
like for for people who who work in this
industry for the women who work in this
industry and she wasn't the only porn
actress who I interviewed she was the
most articulate and and she was one who
I who I put in the book but you know I
was trying to get a sense of what is it
like to do this job she's a woman who
you know is extremely sophisticated has
read widely in political theory
considers herself a feminist and is very
articulate most porn actresses don't fit
that bill and she has a rosier view of
this work and of this industry than
other people on that but but she was she
provided a you know a lot of insight
into how it works and who gets paid and
where
when he goes and etc etc no unions in
the porn world yet did I read that you
you say that there's something like
eleven thousand porn films a year
produced eleven thousand videos very
produce yeah different different titles
some of those may be you know old
material Rhys place together but that's
that's an extraordinary number of titles
what are there you haven't know the
number of movies that are made every
year to go III me it's not one hundred
fifty there's probably about 100 hundred
and fifty something like that but eleven
thousand videos a year they're different
but are they stories most of them are
not stories most of them are just
steamed scenes of sex cut with one
another but the you know yet there's
been a huge growth in the production of
porn the VCR you know took it out of a
dull theaters and put it into people's
homes and it's clearly a product that
people like a lot and want to buy how
many people buy it a year that's a good
question I I don't know the answer to
that but but clearly a lot of them I
mean the the the video store rentals the
number of titles that are rented I think
is seven hundred and seven hundred and
ninety million a year so when you figure
the adult population at about 200
million that's a lot of people are not
doing porn blockbusters what is their
rule off Buster won't carry porn so this
has been a real boon to independent
video stores at a time when they're
competing with blockbuster fiercely
these are you know these are films that
they can rent and earn money from at a
time when blockbuster is driving them
out of business left and right so oddly
enough you know the mom-and-pop video
stores rely a lot more on the revenues
from porn than the big companies whose
Rubin Sterman Rubin Sterman was a figure
who played a central role in the rise of
the pornography industry and you know
every industry has these these great
robber barons these these magnates there
was a history book I'd love to rattle
off the author I can't remember but the
the title of it was the Lords of
creation and it was about the
Rockefellers and the Carnegie's who
built great American industries and
Reuben Thurman was
that for the porn industry and what
struck me about him
what's his picture but is this him
that's him whereas Hugh Hefner and Larry
Flynt courted publicity and love to be
in the paper Rubin sterlin who was much
wealthier and more powerful didn't like
any publicity would appear in public
often with wearing disguises like here
you like here he's got a scratch on that
marks nose on and he run this worldwide
porn empire from the suburb of Shaker
Heights and suburbs of Cleveland Ohio
are you interviewing missus I
interviewed but he's no longer a lot
he's no longer alive he he started out
as a comic book salesman in Cleveland in
the early 1960s late 1950s and basically
was a successful upper middle-class
businessman until he started to sell a
few girlie magazines and branched out
from that and one thing led to another
and created this gigantic porn Empire I
interviewed him once he finally had been
sent to prison by the federal government
the the federal government started
prosecuting him in the early 1960s and
it took almost 30 years for them to
really put him away but I interviewed
him at the end of his life what are the
rules about pornography that's a very
good question I don't know that there
are any rules at the moment I mean right
now the federal federal law forbids the
production or distribution of obscene
material that's a law that was passed in
1873 but the question is what's obscene
and what's not I mean we all have a
fairly good notion of what a murder is
or what an armed robbery is that's a
that's something few of us would argue
about but an obscenity crime is unique
in that it occurs in the mind so
whatever a jury says is obscene is
obscene the federal government has tried
very hard to keep hardcore porn off the
market and in the 1980s in particular
under the Reagan and Bush
administration's really tried to crack
down on porn unfortunately juries even a
very conservative communities kept on
saying hard
Court porn wasn't obscene it's it's kind
of a gray area right now but
nevertheless some very very big
corporations are making a lot of money
off of pornography and in telling the
story of this industry you know Ruben
Sterman being the the robber baron who
really gets it into being a gigantic
worldwide industry he passes from the
scene and the people who are making a
lot of money for porn now have names
like AOL Time Warner Hilton Marriott
they are distributing via satellite and
cable and in their hotel rooms material
that could easily have gotten you sent
to prison in the early 1960s maybe even
in the early 1970s hardcore porn defined
hardcore porn would be sexually explicit
material in which the sex acts are
unmistakably real as opposed to
simulated you know r-rated you know
Hollywood films maybe they're actually
having sex maybe they're not but in
hardcore they really are and it's
visibly so have you done any analysis of
how much money comes in to either the
cable industry or the direct satellite
industry yeah I mean these are these are
rough estimates about four hundred and
sixty five hundred million a year of
porn his throat is sold via cable and
satellite and upwards of 200 million via
hotels so that's a it's a lot of money
Sterman go back to the beginning where
was he from and how did he get into the
comic book business yeah he just you
know he was he he was in the Army Air
Force during World War two got involved
in a candy distributorship in Cleveland
met somebody who had access to
remaindered comic books these were comic
books that were supposed to be returned
to the publisher and shredded but he got
them cheaply somehow and was able to
sell them for a very small amount of
money and he just set up this magazine
distribution network in Cleveland going
to local candy stores and mom-and-pop
stores with his remaindered comic books
and later crossword puzzle books etc etc
and
just happened to be in the right place
in the right time or ultimately maybe
the wrong place in the wrong time he had
a distribution network and at that very
time playboy was successful and there
were a lot of imitators of Playboy and
this was very risque to show women
without their shirts on and his
distribution network was perfect for
selling these girlie magazines so he
started out in the Midwest distributing
girlie magazines and gradually his
empire grew and as films became part of
the porn world he put in these peeps
which showed you know film loop of
sexual activity and that was incredibly
profitable and when he put him in he put
them in the back of the store and in a
booth with the door that could be locked
and there had been stag films you know
dating back to the beginning of the 20th
century that was shown at college
fraternities and Kiwanis Clubs and the
the people allowed men to have a stag
film for one and close the door or lock
the door and feed quarters into this
machine and it was incredibly incredibly
profitable so within a relatively brief
period of time Sterman came to dominate
the production and the distribution of
hardcore pornography not just in the
United States but also throughout the
world in Western Europe as well you
suggest some hypocrisy among
conservatives well not all conservatives
but but one of the things I look at in
the porn section is the the public
morality and the desire to stipe to
stamp out Vice and these these moral
Crusades and the underlying reality not
just about how people are really
behaving but even within the same person
you see this public desire to stamp out
vice and then this private desire to
indulge in it I mean one one example
would be father Bruce Ritter who was a
member of President Reagan's Meese
Commission to investigate pornography
and and Ritter was very adamant by day
that homosexuality should be included in
the Commission's purview and that
homosexuality should be officially
condemned and by night he was cruising
for young male prostitutes and again and
again you see in our history this this
kind of obsession with pornography in
some people being combined with a with a
real desire to indulge in it now I'm not
saying that of all conservatives by any
means or of all critics of pornography
there are a lot of people who criticize
it and and rightly so on its on its
content but when you look at America we
have some of the toughest laws on
pornography in the Western world but we
watch more porn we produce more porn you
know we have a pornographic culture and
the same is true you know for the other
section of the book on marijuana we have
some of the toughest marijuana laws in
the Western world I mean you can get a
life sentence without parole for a
first-time marijuana offense but we grow
more marijuana you know we smoke more
pot we we write more songs about pot I
think that speaks to very deeply
conflicted American psyche and culture
on these issues go back to Bruce Ritter
father Bruce Ritter how did you know
that he cruised at night trying to find
homes he had to he had to step down from
he was the head of Covenant house and it
was revealed I believe one of the young
men Covenant House was a place in New
York City for Runaways a catholic
charity and one of the Runaways that you
know came out publicly and said that he
had been paid to have sex with father
Ritter and there was a scandal that
involved his behavior and he had to he
had to step down you also write about a
man named Charles Keating
yeah and Charles Keating was a was a
it's interesting that a lot of these
people come from roughly the same place
I mean Larry Larry Flynt was from Ohio
Reuben Thurman was from Ohio Charles
Keating who became the nation's biggest
anti-pornography crusader also from Ohio
and starting the late 1950s onward he
was really the the foremost American
opponent of sexually explicit material
but he is interested in the subject you
know from my point of view just seemed a
little bit excessive and in the book I
quote from one of his appearances in
Congress where you know in order to make
his point and his organization
making its point about pornography
they're reading into the Congressional
Record in front of young people who have
come to the Congress that data to watch
these hearings you know relatively
explicit sexual material and he wound up
being involved in the collapse of
Lincoln Savings and Loan you know a huge
Bank scandal in the 1980s and I think
ultimately he's the Keating five
birthday yeah he was the Keating five
and I think ultimately you know a lot of
the Crusaders against vice are human too
and and I think should be more forgiving
of human faults you know he was in glass
houses that that old that old quote and
yet we have these periodic campaigns
against Vice that are very moralistic
and very unforgiving ultimately I mean
I'm not justifying people who smoke too
much pot or people who make pornography
that's you know upsetting but but this
desire to be purer than pure and and
condemn others for their personal habits
is is very American and if you look at
the history of this country we were
founded by Puritans I mean literally by
Puritans but at the same time this
country has a very rebellious and
iconoclastic history and tradition and I
think through all these issues you see
this ongoing battle between the Puritan
part of our culture and and the very
rebellious and iconoclastic you know
dissenting tradition that we have
there's some reference I was looking
forward here in that chapter about
Richard Nixon and Jews and his attitude
yeah about the Jews in pornography this
that was actually about marijuana oh I'm
sorry yeah when it when when when
marijuana was really being debated in
the late 1960s and early 1970s a Nixon
appointed a commission to investigate
what should be done about marijuana in
America and whether it should be
legalized or kept illegal or
decriminalized and when the Commission
that was appointed came out in favor of
decriminalization
he blamed it on the Jews and and that
never happened those recommendations
were never were never carried out but
back to the porn chapter of Philip
Hartley who was hot I'm sorry Philip
horrible Harvey Harvey Philip Harvey is
a very interesting figure who today runs
one of the largest mail-order probably
the largest mail-order pornography
companies in America but he runs it from
North Carolina and he leads a he leads a
double life he's a very articulate very
intelligent Harvard educated expert in
family planning and he uses many much of
the profit from his pornography empire
to fuel charitable work throughout the
developing countries and started out
selling you know birth control and that
same 1873 law that I mentioned earlier
the Comstock tact that forbade obscene
material from being distributed also
forbade the distribution of information
about birth control through the male's
so Harvey started selling condoms and
other birth control information through
the male's fought the father government
in the early 1970s to do that gradually
branched out to sexually explicit
materials and he's like a character out
of a play by George Bernard Shaw in the
sense that he is so purty seems so
conservative personally and and seems
very patrician and seems like an
academic and you would never think in a
million years that here is one of the
most influential and wealthy
pornographers in the United States and
he he you know believes in what he does
he uses the profits for the most part
you know for good ends and he takes the
the products that he sells and subjects
it to you know a commission of sex
therapists to make sure there's nothing
you know horrible about it and he's an
interesting interesting character did
you interview him I did I interviewed
him and he he stood up to the to the
Bush administration the first Bush
administration's war on pornography
because the government realized that
they couldn't get juries to convict
people for obscene material they came up
with a strategy of
indicted people in in many just many
different districts at once so Harvey
was indicted again and again and the
strategy was not to win any individual
case but to come with so many
indictments that you'd have to plea
bargain and go out of business because
you know the government can afford to
depress eight or nine cases at once but
most individuals can't defend themselves
in that many venues you uh you do pay an
interesting picture of Hillsboro North
Carolina yeah how many people there work
in the the cat I can't remember the
exact number but it's I think it's the
biggest private employer in this whole
town
five thousand residents in this chapter
you say yeah I don't know where the
figure is on the number a lot of them
this is a outfit pH pH pH II in karate
and this is Phil Harvey's huge mail
order operation it's run out of
Hillsboro North Carolina selling home it
selling you name at selling hardcore
videos selling sexual devices selling
books very the kinds of things that you
find in a New York City sex shop but he
argues that this is the most socially
responsible way to sell this material
you're not imposing it on anyone you you
know you're not you're not putting it
into anyone's face the marketing or
anything like that it's done but it's
done through the mail it's done very
discreetly and this is a very
conservative community that doesn't seem
to mind his business and and most of his
employees are women and did you see that
mean yeah you know I wouldn't I went
into the warehouse and I just saw this
vast high-tech warehouse in which you
know all these packages are being sorted
and very dainty white haired Southern
women are handling material that you
would not normally think that they would
be handling and packaging and boxing but
I think you know if you visit that
operation you you get a sense of how
much a part of the mainstream in America
this material has become and these
objects have become in his own area
juries won't convict him because they
believe that adults should be able to
see what they want to see in the privacy
of their own homes this is a far cry
from the early 1960s again when Ruben
Sturman was starting out Lenny Bruce the
comedian was imprisoned for saying a few
swear words which I won't say in this
show during his nightclub act it's
remarkable what you could be prosecuted
for in the in the early 60s and what
you'd see on HBO today is far more
explicit than what people were sent to
prison for 30 35 years ago you think of
fellow rather strongly in the back by
the name of Ross Felder yes who was he
rich Frost Felder was a was a federal
agent and in Cleveland with the
organized crime strike force and he
became intrigued with Rubens German this
this porn magnate of Cleveland because
no one really knew much about him and
the FBI had been trying for more than a
decade to get Sturman indicted and
convicted on obscenity charges but the
more that Ross Felder learned about
sternman's operation the more he thought
that Sterman was a multi million dollar
tax cheat and Ross Felder was a criminal
investigator for the IRS and in order to
avoid giving money to the government
Sterman had created an unbelievably
Byzantine corporate structure the sort
of thing that Enron created a couple of
decades later to shift money from
various off through various offshore
corporations and offshore banks and
Sherman felt that he had no obligation
to subsidize the government that was
trying to put him into prison so Ross
Felder started investigating Sterman I
think in 1975 and spent almost 20 years
pursuing him dogged Lee throughout the
world to build a case against him
and eventually did bring him down but a
very honorable Ross felt or a very good
guy very honorable guy and really to me
a model public servant so he wasn't
after the porn side of this he was after
the tax cheats I I don't think that that
rich is a great fan of pornography but
what offended him was the idea here was
a multi-million dollar tax sheet and in
a very arrogant one
Sterman had a lot of hubris he after the
first time the FBI raided his his
warehouse in 63 he responded by suing J
Edgar Hoover now this was at the height
of Hoover's power so Sterman was a very
arrogant guy who really believed in his
own intellect and his own abilities and
it's it's remarkable how many times
sermon did beat the federal government
and how close he came even to winning
the tax case you know as I write in the
book he tried to he tried to tamper with
the jury and after spending you know
almost two decades pursuing Rubin
sterling Russ Felder is quite blunt now
about how if Sterman had managed to
tamper with the jury and there'd been a
mistrial sermon might have walked free
and and never gone to prison what was
the story about the the juror that was
his second wife picked out and tried out
in the middle of the trial Sherman had a
very attractive young life and there was
a young male juror who received a note
from her and the juror had no idea this
was the lead defendants wife but the
note suggested they meet later on and he
wound up going out to dinner with her
and she clearly offered him she tried to
persuade him to define Stormin not
guilty and it's quite possible that a
different juror this juror this juror
wound up voting to convict but a
different juror might have accepted
money or sexual favors in return for a
not guilty plea and that would have been
the end of the government case and and
Sterman might have walked free did you
talk to either the juror or the second
wife no I didn't in in focusing on
Sherman and his career I again this is
this this is about the the the sections
about pornography but it's a business
it's a business piece it's it's a the
book is a business book and I really
tried not to get too involved in his
personal life I never sought out his
children I never sought out his ex-wives
I wasn't as interested in that personal
side of his life but just in how he
built this Empire
go back to the she was she was later
to present for her role in tampering
with the jury so did catch her on this
they did catch her on this and and so
you know in writing about family members
I try to write about them to the degree
that you know they were convicted of
various crimes but not to get into his
personal life you say they rich Ross
teller took 20 years almost 20 years how
many times was Sterman tribe he was he
was trial or anything like I can't I
can't remember the number but it seemed
as though he was tried every two years
or so how many times a comment on on
federal obscenity on state obscenity
charges again and again he was tried for
the content of the material that he was
selling and he beat the rap every single
time and every time that he beat the rap
his stature grew even larger in the porn
industry he was adamant about beating
the federal government and he would
subsidize the legal fees of other people
in the industry even if they were rivals
if they would stand up to the government
and it wasn't until the end when he'd
already been convicted on tax charges
that he decided to plead guilty to an
obscenity charge in Las Vegas and so if
you if you think of the federal
government tried to get him on obscenity
charges dating back to 1963 and it took
it took 28 years for them to get him on
a single charge
he had brilliant lawyers and he was
willing to fight you know any any
indictment in the middle that you talk
about him moving money offshore yeah and
I want to ask you about that what are
the rules today I know you moved them to
Swiss banks he also moved it to Lipkin
Stein yeah
so what today and I think the Virgin
Islands in there somewhere yeah what is
what are the rules today about moving
money offshore well you know an IRS
agent would be better worse than me to
tell you what the taxation implications
are but Sterman really pioneered all
kinds of very innovative methods of
money laundering and you know by trying
to get the money offshore he didn't want
to just park it offshore he wanted to be
able to use it in the United States so
he would set up various corporations or
establishments he did it in
Liechtenstein he did it in Panama he did
it in the Cayman Islands and then those
offshore corporations
be making investments in the United
States and the IRS doesn't have access
to offshore corporations and and their
books but you know towards the end of my
book I talk about how what Sterman was
doing and pioneering many corporations
in the United States you know I'm sure
they've looked at the tax law very
carefully are not breaking the law on
doing it but the strategy has been
similar to avoid paying taxes in the
United States there's been a big boom in
the last ten years of what it called
inversion transactions which is American
companies that have all their facilities
in the United States taking out a
mailbox overseas and calling themselves
foreign corporations to avoid paying tax
in sternman's case he didn't want to pay
taxes result for philosophical reasons
he didn't want to give this government
that was trying to put him in prison a
single penny but I think he also wanted
to enjoy as much of his money as he
could he died again in what year he died
I think in 1997 he died in a federal
prison and by then you know when I met
him he he was like a proud and deposed
head of state he claimed to be
completely broke although that's never
really been proven if he was I mean he
might have had millions of dollars
parked on offshore accounts that Ross
Felder and the IRS never found and the
porn industry had moved on I mean it had
become corporate it had these
relationships with the satellites and
the cable companies and Sterman
increasingly seemed like a a figure from
the shadowy past there were allegations
that Sterman had links to organized
crime to the Gambino family and so by
the time I met him he was a very bright
very articulate lonely man in a prison
in Kentucky whose time had clearly
passed want to go to another section but
first when I ask you a couple
philosophical questions about the book
long detailed source notes in the back
yeah but relatively short book is that
your philosophy well I've got to be
careful that the the source notes never
become longer than the actual book
I believe in transparency as much as
possible
with the work and and the same was true
with fast food nation for readers who
are interested in something I've written
who want to read more about it the
source notes are there for readers who
don't believe what I'm saying and want
to see where that came from and check it
for themselves the source notes are
there for people who might think of
suing me for libel the source notes are
there so I'm trying to trying to be very
careful as a journalist and also not
rely on unnamed sources and and and and
expect the reader just to take my word
that these things are true if you look
at fast food nation and you look at this
book there are a lot of things in it
that are potentially controversial that
I haven't been written about extensively
before and I'm not expecting anyone to
just take my word on it and and so I'm
gonna try to keep the source notes under
control for the next book but I feel you
know there are no footnotes in the texts
of people who want to read the book and
never look at the source notes that's
just fun but people who are curious or
questioning or litigious can can look at
the source notes and and and see that
it's all it's all there where I got
things put it in context it's about 60
pages out of 300 overall the other thing
would ask you about is this book cover
yeah I've never seen one like it yeah
it's this I'm holding it sideways so the
audience can read it this idea was it
not mine but I like it I like that I
like that there's that pull quote from
the book which gives you on the cover
you know one of the central themes of
the book which is that these black
markets and the mainstream are pretty
much linked together and I try in the
book to show that this is one country
America and there's something artificial
about dividing these markets from the
rest of our markets how big is the black
market it's huge and an economist agree
that it's really been growing since
around 1970 but what its actual size is
nobody knows I mean I I try to use
statistics from a conservative Austrian
economist who is doing work for the
International Monetary Fund his
estimates are
eight to ten percent of our gross
domestic product that would be about a
trillion dollars when the IRS in 1998
looked at how much money you know people
were evading in taxes they came up with
a estimate of two hundred billion
dollars was not being paid in taxes and
that would mean about a trillion and a
half dollars in income was not being
reported and that doesn't include
illegal activity so it's huge it's
gigantic who is Mark young mark young
was a hippie biker who I wrote about in
the marihuana section of the book and
he's no saint but but he's certainly no
serial killer where is he from he's from
Indiana where in in in Indianapolis and
he was involved in a marijuana deal he
didn't grow the pot he didn't sell the
pot or distribute it but he introduced a
grower to a distributor and took a cut
on some of their sales and when this
marijuana growing operation was shut
down mark young refused to cooperate
with the government refused to testify
against anybody refused to admit that he
was guilty he's a very proud marijuana
smoker and as a result for his first
marijuana crime he was sentenced to life
without parole and sent to a very scary
federal penitentiary in Kansas did you
go see him I did and that was that was
quite an experience Leavenworth
Penitentiary is a very scary building
and it was designed to be that way it
was the first federal penitentiary and
it's very strange its architecture is
modeled on that of the US Capitol
building but it's it's this you know
Siddall the the Capitol building is like
our symbol of freedom but somehow
they've transformed that into a symbol
of very it's a scary place very very
keep on saying that an old prison and
very dangerous very you know that's
where they send convicted international
terrorists and and killers and here was
this hippie biker there for pot deal how
old is he he was oh she's probably about
48 now he was in his mid-30s when he got
sent to prison he wound up
after after I wrote about him for the
Atlantic Monthly and after the article
came out his life sentence was reduced
to 12 years which is still longer than
the typical convicted killer spends in
prison in the United States
so in the marijuana section I'm trying
to come to terms with how do we punish
someone more for marijuana in America
than for killing somebody with a gun you
list a number of conservatives that are
for the decriminalization of marijuana
is there any way to put people in
classes as to what they think about
smoking marijuana well you know it's
it's it's generally a very certain kind
of moralistic conservative who has led
the prohibition of marijuana and is in
favor of these very tough sentences the
current drug czar John Waters is in
favor of increasing some of the
penalties for marijuana and yet there
are other conservatives who come from a
much more libertarian tradition and not
as much of a moralistic tradition like
William Buckley Milton Friedman George
Schultz who have called for the
decriminalization of marijuana and and
the traditional political labels don't
always apply when it comes to the war on
drugs a lot of the tough legislation was
eagerly sponsored by Liberal Democrats
and we've had one president who's
admitted to having a joint in his mouth
which was Bill Clinton and more people
were sent to prison and arrested for
marijuana during the Clinton
administration
than during any other presidency more
people were sent to prison while Clinton
was president than during any of any
other presidents say you say I'll just
read him off to the third of the
population of smoked marijuana that 20
million smoked at a year that two men
smoked it every day and that half of the
I mean most of the marijuana in this
country is grown in the America's
heartland yeah yeah I mean Indiana was
all over this yeah look I mean the
reason that I wrote you know the way
that the book works is that marijuana is
a black market commodity illegal
immigrants are black market labor and
then pornography is an example of how a
little black market becomes mainstream I
you know I wrote about marijuana and not
cocaine for a number of reasons it's the
most widely used illegal drug in the
United States it's the most popular and
it's also the one that we produce here
you can't blame this problem on
Colombian cartels this is an
all-american crop it's being grown you
know not just in Northern California or
Hawaii which is or Kentucky which are
the popular stereotypes of marijuana
growing but I wrote about a very
profitable marijuana farm in Indiana
it's being grown widely in Illinois in
Missouri and no one knows for sure but
but I believe and I contend in the book
that most of the marijuana being grown
in the United States is coming from the
farm belt and it some people believe
it's our largest cash crop in the United
States corn is our corn crop is worth
about nineteen billion dollars some
people think our marijuana crop may be
worth as much as twenty five billion but
in any event it's huge because you know
apples which is our biggest fruit I mean
that's about a billion dollars a year
and so even if it's five billion or ten
billion in marijuana that's a huge huge
American industry and and again coming
out of the heartland you say between a
hundred and two hundred thousand
commercial growers in the United States
that's a that's a rough estimate that
comes from an old federal drug
investigative report but clearly if
twenty million people are smoking at a
year you need a lot of people to grow it
and the the estimate of two million a
day smoking it and 20 million a year
these come from government surveys in
which people are asked if they smoke
marijuana and most likely that
understates the number considerably
because given the marijuana laws that we
have now I think a fair number of people
aren't going to tell the government
sincerely and honestly if they're if
they're using marijuana or growing it if
they arrested you or me and we had
smoked it yeah what's the is your
mandatory sentence no it's a very
unusual type of crime in the sense that
a marijuana crime can be subject to
local law state law and federal law
simultaneously and as a matter of fact
if you're arrested with some marijuana
and found innocent under local law
you're
under your state law the federal
government could still prosecute you for
the same marijuana and send you to
prison I mean I write about a marijuana
grower in Florida who was found innocent
or who was given a very minor sentence
under state law and then was prosecuted
for the same marijuana under federal law
and given a given a life sentence it
varies it entirely depends on who
arrests you who decides to prosecute you
and what they decide to prosecute you
for and one of the big themes of this
section is the amazing increase in
prosecutorial power as a result because
under federal law marijuana is illegal
in every state of the Union in any
amount so technically the federal
government could prosecute anybody
arrested for marijuana anywhere in the
United States in practical terms they
don't do that but if there's a
prosecutor who doesn't like you and
really wants to cause you a hard time
you can be in big trouble
even for you know relatively small
amounts of marijuana how many people are
in prison or jail today because of
marijuana very very hard to calculate
and the best estimate I could come up
with is about 20,000 in federal prison
thirty thirty-five thousand in in state
prison and jail is very hard to guess
but a lot the the one area that's looked
at marijuana arrests for possession just
for simple possession of marijuana and
and who goes to jails in Maryland they
did a study and they found that one out
of every four people arrested went to
jail for at least a night and one out of
every six arrested went to jail for at
least a week and that's a lot of people
when you figure the nationwide about
700,000 people are arrested for pot
every year and that's more than for any
other drug before we run out of time I
asked you about your mother and father
what about your own family he married
you have kids I'm married and I have two
kids how old are they and they're 10 and
12 and I look forward to the day when I
let them read one of my books so far my
daughter's maybe a year or so away from
that why is that this is these are very
disturbing subjects often I mean in Fast
Food Nation
you know the meatpacking section is
is very is very graphic and and I think
very upsetting and you know I think I'll
wait a year or so before I want my
daughter reading about hardcore
pornography
what's your own attitude about your kids
as they grow up about all this fast
foods pornography smoking marijuana you
know I want them to obey the law I've
really seen the consequences of seeming
seemingly trivial offenses and how that
can destroy a life I mean if you're
caught with any amount of marijuana and
convicted of a misdemeanor you can have
student loans taken away for life so I'd
like them to obey the law but I'd also
like them to grow up questioning the law
and not just accepting the status quo
and and thinking for themselves so you
know try to give them a sound moral
foundation and then they're gonna have
to figure out these issues for
themselves this book as we read earlier
says that you're already at work on that
book on the American prison system that
come out of all this it did it came out
of I mean I'd never been in a prison
before in my life before visiting
Leavenworth Penitentiary
I had to see mark Young locked up there
for pot and in looking at our drug laws
and in looking at the black market and
it really made me think about our prison
system and who's in prison and why and
and that's the next book when is that
gonna come out I've got a I've got to
finish writing it I'd say a year and a
half something like that and at this
stage in your career are you happy with
way things are going there's no novels
here these are all there's books
absolutely no compliant to be able to
write about what you care about and to
get it published and you know what I'm
trying to do is make people think about
these issues so to the degree that there
can be a public discussion of them
because of what I've written no
complaints
and on the first book anything happened
as a result of your book Fast Food
Nation any legislation any I don't know
I mean I'm I'm where to claim any cosmic
global credit for anything that I've
read and I've found individual people
that I've met have told me that it
changed their eating habits or changed
their view of things and that's
very gratifying I think that a lot of
the issues are dealt with in Fast Food
Nation are now part of the public debate
and maybe that would have happened
anyway but but but I feel it's that that
was very gratifying experience our guest
has been Eric Schlosser and this is the
cover of the book and is the way we're
showing it here at it's really the right
way except that if you in order to read
it I got turned this way and the book is
called reefer madness thank you very
much for joining thank you